construye un triángulo equilátero
inscrito dentro del círculo bueno aquí
lo que voy a hacer es usar el compás
para tener una circunferencia que sea
exactamente del mismo tamaño de mi
circunferencia original ahora esto la
voy a tomar y la voy a mover de manera
que el centro de esta nueva
circunferencia toque la circunferencia
original y a su vez el centro de mi
circunferencia original esté tocando la
circunferencia de la nueva
circunferencia que dibuje o del nuevo
círculo que dibuje ahora voy a utilizar
la regla si yo uno este punto de acá con
este otro punto de acá esto de que iba a
ser un radio
ambas circunferencias tienen el mismo
tamaño por lo que tienen el mismo radio
este es un radio si yo uso otro segmento
para unir este punto con este punto de
acá en donde se intersectan ambas
circunferencias pues esto también mide
un radio es el radio de el nuevo círculo
o de la nueva circunferencia y si uno a
su vez
estos otros dos puntos este y este
también mide un radio el radio de la
circunferencia original que es el mismo
que de la circunferencia nueva y aquí
tengo un triángulo equilátero cada uno
de estos lados es un radio este es un
radio este es un radio y ese es un radio
lo interesante de esto es que si esto es
un triángulo equilátero entonces cada
uno de estos ángulos va a medir 60
grados qué pasa si yo hago esto 1 esta
parte de acá de la circunferencia con el
centro hagan de cuenta que estoy
dibujando otro triángulo pero invertido
es un triángulo como el de aquí arriba
pero está de cabeza entonces si cada uno
de estos ángulos de los triángulos
pequeños son de 60 grados si aquí tengo
60 grados y aquí abajo también tengo 60
grados todo esto será un ángulo de 120
grados este arco de aquí medidas 120
grados 120 grados es la tercera parte
del círculo y también base es 1
lados de nuestro triángulo inscrito
dentro del círculo si yo uno este punto
con este otro tendré un lado de mi
triángulo equilátero ahora voy a
reutilizar la circunferencia la voy a
poner aquí de manera que toque estos dos
puntos que ya tengo y el centro esté de
nuevo tocando la circunferencia original
y de nuevo aquí voy a tener otro
triángulo y aquí voy a tener otro
triángulo pequeño voy a quitar este voy
a poner aquí
y de acá aunque no tengo que dibujar
todos los triángulos internos porque me
interesa nada más dibujar los lados del
triángulo que me piden aquí tendríamos
otros triángulos y todo esto sería un
arco de 120 grados y ahora voy a
utilizar estas mismas líneas que ya
tengo para dibujar la secante que va a
ser el lado de mi triángulo equilátero y
bueno ya tengo dos lados iguales lo
único que me queda es unir voy a usar
esta estos dos puntos de acá para tener
mi triángulo equilátero circunscrito a
esta circunstancia